carlos construyó una mesa rectangular
que tiene un perímetro de 20 pies y un
área de 24 pies cuadrados la mesa es más
larga que ancha cuáles son el largo y el
ancho de la mesa el largo y el ancho son
números enteros entonces es más larga
que ancha a ver dibujemos la mesa así es
que la mesa se vería más o menos así
más o menos así así sería la mesa esta
dimensión de aquí es el largo esta
dimensión de aquí es el largo vamos a
escribirlo largo también de este lado
podemos escribir largo para resaltar que
esta dimensión es igual a esta y esta
dimensión de aquí este otro lado de aquí
es el ancho el ancho que también
corresponde a la longitud de este lado
de acá ancho esto es un rectángulo así
es que estos dos lados son iguales y nos
dicen que el perímetro es igual a 20
pies es decir que si sumamos ancho más
ancho
más largo
más de largo
es igual a 20 pies y también nos dicen
que el área es de 24 pies cuadrados es
decir el producto de ancho por largo es
24 pies cuadrados el producto de ancho x
largo
ancho por largo es igual a igual a 24
pies cuadrados hay muchas maneras de
resolver esto posteriormente cuando
aprendas álgebra vas a aplicar técnicas
fascinantes pero por lo pronto nos están
diciendo que el largo y el ancho son
números enteros
así es que solo necesitamos probar
algunos números pues sabemos que ancho
por largo es igual a 24 lo único que
necesitamos es probar esos números
enteros que al tomar su producto nos da
24 básicamente encontrar los factores de
24 y probar cuáles de ellos cumplen con
el perímetro tomar el ancho más el ancho
dos veces el ancho más dos veces el
largo y verificar que eso nos da 20
hagamos eso encontremos esos valores voy
a poner aquí cuatro columnas una de
ancho
en la siguiente columna voy a poner los
valores posibles de largo luego voy a
poner el perímetro quizás voy a ponerlo
como per
pero no voy a escribir todo completo
perímetro y en la última columna voy a
poner los valores de área vamos a hacer
una tabla aquí vamos a hacer una tabla
que nos permita aprobar los distintos
valores lo que necesitamos es
asegurarnos que los valores que
encontremos de ancho y largo produzcan
un área de 24 pies cuadrados es decir
que sean factores de 24 bien podrían ser
1 y 24 un ancho de 1 x un largo de 24
producen un área de 24 y nos dicen que
la mesa es más larga que ancha es decir
es decir lo que mide a lo largo es mayor
que lo que mide a lo ancho entonces 1
por 24 es 24 pero cuánto es uno más uno
más 24 más 24 112 24 y 24 48 esto nos da
igual a 50/50 es distinto de 20
así es que estas dimensiones no cumplen
con la condición de
perímetro es igual a 20 vamos a tachar
este porque no es la solución que otros
factores tenemos también tenemos 2 por
12 2 por 2 se nos da 24 pero cuánto es
dos más dos cuatro más 12 12 24 4 más 24
28 28 28
no es el perímetro de 20 que queremos
así es que este resultado tampoco nos
sirve que otros factores tenemos tenemos
3 y 83 por 8 24 y ahora 33 36 88 16 16
63 22 nos estamos acercando pero este
resultado tampoco nos funciona probemos
ahora 4 y 6-4 por 6 24 y cuánto es 446
más 68 más 12 igual a 20 estas son
efectivamente las dimensiones que
estamos buscando así es que carlos
construyó una mesa de 4 pulgadas de
largo
por 6 pulgadas de ancho